uh so let's do let's do a 15 minute game
to start
down a queen um unless you want to do
10 minutes but i think 15 minutes is
good just for now because yeah
you know it gives me a chance to run off
at the mouth
we'll do 15 plus two
[Music]
so first go uh go move your knight out
to f3
and now uh play like pawn to e4
oh my god oh [ __ ] my my marbles
whatever has remained in my brain is now
mush
unbelievable okay so
uh you know i'm not going to like help
you directly find moves i want you to
talk through your logic
and i'll help you in that way okay
sounds good
i feel like i got to get wacky to to
beat you here
that could mean a lot of different
things yeah like i'm talking real
[ __ ] wacky dude
okay i like the way that sounds yeah to
e2 okay
so let's go i'm gonna develop so
i want you i want to remind you as
you're thinking of the main
goal that you're going to have at some
point you want to develop normally but
at some point you want to open up the
center
yeah because without opening up the
center your extra queen is just going to
be a freaking
it's just going to be sitting there
which is what you basically want anyway
just for it to be sitting there okay
anyways i won't distract you
okay
oh countering the old wacky strats i
like it
dude you think i haven't dealt with
wacky
i've dealt with every i've dealt with an
opponent who has brought a real sword to
the game
what the [ __ ] does that mean you fought
against like a samurai chess player
i think i might have told the story but
i i played this and by the way i can add
time
i think i can i'm supposed to be able to
add time to your clock but we're not
friends on chess.com
i added you as a friend can you accept
that yeah it's about [ __ ] time
i mean yeah is it okay for friends i
it's funny because
there are some people some students who
are like hey daniel i added you as a
friend on chess.com
like months ago and you never accepted
and i feel so bad about it because it's
just like i get a million requests and
stuff
it's not easy being the world's most
handsome grandmaster oh
well now you're making me blush that's
not the direction i wanted this to go
okay so your feet what is this i almost
gave it away what is what you just did
called
fianchetto yes all right so let me try
to
uh complicate the position a little bit
and see how you react
uh to immediate threats i'm gonna take
your knight
oh i don't like that daniel
well i like that you don't like it all
right
so let's see i'm gonna go here
well i muted myself so i'm attacking
charlie's night let's see how he reacts
to this
hmm that move scares the living [ __ ]
interview doesn't it
i don't like that move because now
you're throwing off my big wacky strats
and i i can't give up this bishop which
means i have to push queen e4 i think is
the only vote
nice that's the best move defend again
using one piece to defend the other
piece
and by the way um let's calculate a
little bit in your head if i take your
bishop what do you do
i'm just taking back with the queen and
then if i take your e5 pawn with my
knight
find the best move i'm taking your g7
pawn
and then find the best move for black
you are forking the knight on the rook
can one piece move away and defend the
other
i'm not gonna do any of this but just
calculation practice yeah yeah if you
were a fool
um if i was a fool exactly so queen's on
g7 i'm attacking
rook and knight
yeah you just bring knight to g6 and
then what is white's best move can white
and this is like those movie scenes
where one you know someone has their
hands on the ledge and you're prying
their fingers away
the knight is defending the rook you see
that construction can you attack that
knight
with one of your i'm just bringing the
pawn up
bingo h5 that's good calculation so for
that reason
i'm just gonna drop my knife back for
that
simple reason it seems like i put the
fear of god in you there
oh yeah keep telling yourself that he's
attacking my pawn oh i'm telling
yourself that yeah that's pretty good
visualization
well i don't want to give up this pawn
because i feel like it's a pretty strong
pawn here at e5 so i think i have to
push
f4 bring another defender in
f4 is protected by queen as well that's
not bad
but remember you want to usually kill
two birds you want to do
many things at once you haven't
controlled the center yet
right and f4 by the way would give up h4
yeah i was just about to say
my coverage yeah okay so i think in this
position i'm just bringing the other
pawn then at d4
yeah yeah people need to hear the sword
story so this was
2006 i was playing a tournament la and i
went with my coach
because my coach at that time was from
los angeles and my coach was armenian
so he he was like a russian coach and
even rick more
strict and i'm playing this guy
and i i [ __ ] you not and this is
anybody can corroborate this he comes to
the game in what is it called
chain link armor like literally
and he is literally carrying a sword a
fully sheathed sword
and i freak out and this guy was kind of
known in the chess community he had some
some issues
but i freaked out and i tell my coach
like armin i'm playing a guy and he
brought a
sword to the game i'm afraid of like
winning
and he laughs his ass off and he's like
that's that's a fake sword he's just
he's just you know
he's just [ __ ] with you uh but later
it was discovered
that this was an actual real sword and
there was a lot of things he did during
the game it was just weird as hell
at one point he got up for like 45
minutes on his turn
and he came back with some like half
eaten hamburger that looked disgusting
and he ultimately won the game in seven
hours it was one of the longest games
i've ever played of course
yeah nice on facant damn girl
yes sir see i still got the moves out
here
the sauce
okay now what
but my development it's looking like
something yeah right now it is
exactly get your damn pieces
out so castling on this feet well what
was a fee in keto isn't a good idea
right like now i want to castle long
well um yeah so ideally you would want
to cast a long remember i also don't
have a queen so
if i had a queen you're correct the
logic is good
the fact of the matter is i don't have
the resources necessary to attack you
even if you were to castle short but
here's what i would recommend
uh there's two ways of developing you
can literally develop you can also push
my pieces away from their good positions
and there is one move you can make to
push away one of my pieces
from its good position you have found
this move earlier in a different context
it's a developmental move it's not
really it's a pawn move i'll give you
that
you don't have to play yes right yep
okay
this is what my friend calls moving your
opponent's pieces so you're like
undeveloping my pieces
now this gives me an active square to
develop too now right going to g5 with
this bishop
that's a good move yep okay i'm going to
well okay i'm going to go f6j i don't
want to i don't want to trade anything
but that's a weakening move so you have
actually achieved something
i know it makes you feel really good
i'm gonna go here control the center
now i'm going to play i've consulted the
ghost of traxler and he's told me to
play this
oh i don't like that spirit
now you need to do some damage control
you have to figure out what i am
threatening i have a very big threat
in this position it's this it's c2
am i threatening to capture it oh no
because it's
guarded by queen okay so what am i
threatening to do
i thought then cut those nuts off but um
your queen is guarding the square
remember that the queen is the worst
defender because the queen is a very
easy piece to attack
what am i threatening to attack it with
are you gonna move the pawn at it
i'm going to move the yeah pawn or
bishop even bishop on bishop f5 is
better
oh because then that gets me off of d3
as well okay so the way you should think
about it is
you're probably thinking how do i get my
queen away you don't have to do that
what you have to do is defend the c2
pawn so that you will be able to move
the queen when you when it's attacked
how can you defend c2 while developing a
piece it's not the greatest looking move
but
just keep bringing the knight to the rim
at a3 bingo
that's a very powerful move actually but
the logic makes sense right
yeah okay okay i want to do this anyway
now the queen has only one square
yeah and that's dropping it to e3
correct
yes and by the way otherwise um i would
have taken on c2 and forked or king and
queen
i think someone just offered ironclad
logic i didn't realize this
wait aren't they playing against each
other why is donya helping him
surely he's lowering his chance of
winning man
i think i think i need to stop stop
helping you to be fair
you haven't been giving me like answers
to questions i haven't asked
exactly that's sort of the that start
and i'm just teasing you don't worry
gigi
you are a valued member of the community
okay i'm going to take on t2 with the
bishop
yeah i can't take that back because then
i get forked
so
you haven't been okay with me answers to
questions i haven't asked that's like
unexpectedly profound
i feel like that definitely is what
people do when they want you to like
do stuff correctly yeah
i think this is a good move uh it is
okay it is it is yeah getting the rook
to the open file and you don't really
care about pawns here
because you're up a queen that's so much
material what you care about is
getting your pieces to good squares
completing your development
and and then starting the attack at some
point
so speaking of completing your
development there's one thing you
haven't done
yeah yeah and you can't castle along
anymore that's okay but it's
it's better to at least castle some
somewhere yeah get the king out of the
middle
exactly and so will i
oh baby um
he just lost
so i keep looking at this move but i
don't know if it's good if i think
you're looking at the correct move which
one is it
c7 with ropes yes yes i'm
actually pumped you found this move see
the seventh rank forking the knight on
the pawn
my knight on e7 is kind of constricted
by all of my other pieces
i'm gonna make a gm level move right now
okay i'm gonna pull something on you
that's kind of sexy if i may say so
myself
i'm so stupid oh no what is it he's just
giving up his knight for free what
this guy's gone wacko mode bro like dude
like man like rook takes c7 right on bro
oh yeah so what's the you see the idea
but actually i'm also defending the pawn
on b7
okay um
let's see what do i want to do
so you you understand the like the the
main ideas of this
i think so for the most part
you were forking what do i want to do if
you take my knife
you're going to trap my rook how
uh you're going to bring
isn't it just move no you get well if
you move rook e8 that doesn't work
uh yeah then you just take the rope so
think about when you're struggling with
a move
what squares have been left behind as a
consequence of my last move so bishop
has moved away from what square
f5 which means what can move on to that
now
onto that square
yes and what would that accomplish they
would then be forking like
bishop and your rook if your rook were
to move to east yeah
that's the idea it's like that bobby
fischer story i can tell after the game
okay i thought you were trapping the
rook but i just see i could take the
rook on e8
right yeah if a rook attacks the rook
you can just take the joke
amazing formulation um
so in this position well let's see if i
play
h4 or not h4 h3 with this bishop here
is that a decent move looking to trade
bishops and get rid of this attack
that's a great move actually and trading
in general is
is a good move actually
it wasn't a great move but i actually
blundered the response
to it i swear i did not mean to sabotage
i won't play the move that
but i want you now to tell me why this
is actually a bad move i actually forgot
that this leaves something undefended
uh well now the g file on my king
is open but i don't right but will i
will i ever get a rook to
the g file and actually you are the only
one who can get a rook to the g
file yeah it doesn't really look like
you can attack that
um i oh it leaves my pawn undefended so
you still get it out and you're taking
queen
mark yeah can we get my rook yeah
exactly exactly so uh in general this is
an advanced concept but when there is a
pawn that's not defended by any other
pawns
that's something you should sort of mark
in your mind as something you need to
watch out for
like a position is like a map and
you need to understand like where where
the big cities are where are the
pressure points on the map otherwise you
get freaking
mental overflow or overload and um
you know your brain auto filters the
stuff it thinks is important
but chess doesn't follow the same rules
as you know as life so
uh you need to retrain your brain to
look at the important things that's my
speech
so what a better move well obviously
this was a bad one but if would a better
move have been pushing this
f4 pawn and opening up the center yes oh
f4 would have been really
really sexy okay that would have
actually been i believe the best move
i'm actually going to take your bishop
and then i'm going to take on d5
okay that's very sweet of you so let me
just take this picture i know i'm always
there for you know
honestly
yeah let's just get something out of
this here
bingo that's good i'm gonna f4
nice nice nice this is not for the next
fock champs guys charlie just loves
chess
and i like teaching with chess we're
just doing a lesson no reason for it
all right so you're attacking mate
you're threatening mate
i am going to scare you with this move
which of course you saw
yeah that is a very scary move
that's
um
i only have one movie i just going back
to h1
lose bishop but i still get made right
yep
if you take yeah exactly g7 is saying so
i have to do this to defend against the
mate
i don't know guys full disclosure i have
no idea that charlie's in pogchamps
three i honestly don't know
if he is we're gonna grind so hard he's
gonna beat everybody
i don't know i feel like
the check at e6 is kind of strong
because then it forces you to age eight
right
you can't but that's a good thing for me
then the king withdraws further into its
inner circle
a good way to think about this position
is in terms of undefended pieces
what name blacks two main undefended
pieces
uh well you have the f3 knight which is
undefended by anything
and also h5 bingo can you slide a piece
over and attack both at the same time
g4 bingo now that's not necessarily
winning a piece because i can do
what okay
what can i do here like what would you
do if you were black i suppose
that saves both nights uh well it
doesn't necessarily
save both knights it it doesn't lose a
piece
oh you um
yeah i want you to find this move
because this is important and it
it comes from understanding how to think
about the position when two pieces are
under attack
so there's a a step of logic you go
through number one
can you move one piece defend the other
piece the answer is no knights are
diagonally placed they cannot by
definition defend each other right
right next question can i move one of
the pieces
and attack one of my opponent's pieces
so or take one of my opponent's pieces
i i i think no that doesn't work i was
gonna say you just push
pawn but that's not gonna do it that
only defense one night can you
attack an opponent's piece or take an
opponent's feet so can one of the
knights take anything that belongs to
you
the bishop yeah and that's exactly
that's it that's all i meant
right because you always save a piece
but the trade is good for you because
you're now removing defenders from my
king and you're getting closer to
delivering checkmate
does it matter which knight i take here
or is it no cool actually it really
doesn't um
it's you know semantic difference
i'm just gonna take this bad boy then
absolutely
knock yourself out and go here
now you need to
activate the pieces that are not doing
anything that's yeah exactly
yeah what other pieces do anything the
knight
yeah you might not need it i'm actually
gonna make a move that sets you up for a
combination that wins the game but i'm
not going to tell you what this
combination is
okay this forcibly
ends in checkmate in a couple of moves
it's a winning crushing idea
let's see if you can find it take your
time
okay so i muted myself the correct move
of course is you guys are saying
is to take the knight right just taking
knight at g6 right with rook
you take i take that's amazing because i
just muted myself to tell my chat with
the correct movies and just as i was
saying that you actually said the move
that's actually crazy
okay and
i'm going to give you the scariest check
in history that is [ __ ] wild yeah
yeah
freaking brought the house down yeah
and then i'm just taking rook first and
then going in right there's nothing you
can do to stop it
yup do this
and some people think gm's can pull
pieces out of their behinds but
unfortunately i cannot
does it matter what i do at this point
like if i take with the rook it doesn't
matter if i take with the queen it still
it doesn't
check made in two moves now most people
would be drawn to taking with the queen
because that's check but i literally
have no pieces left
so you can pre-move the ch i want you to
pre-move the checkmating move
like when i make a move i want it to be
pre-moved ready okay
ready great just make it sure
nice so that was really interesting
actually i'm curious what you were going
for in the opening
um and i won't bore you too much of the
game
let me invite you yeah i i had a talking
big [ __ ] about wacko wacko wow i wasn't
sure exactly what it is that you were
actually going for
okay so after my brilliancy on move
two okay so explain yourself
okay so at this point what i wanted to
do i wanted to just
get some kind of cheeky little like
pre-emptive attack on the king and open
up the middle of the board so
what i wanted to do at some point was
play this move and get this to happen so
i'd have queen in position
uh sorry let me look because it's not
showing the arrows so you're saying
oh knight f5 e takes off iv takes f5 oh
you wanted to open the e file
yeah i wanted to get this open asap and
start putting pressure maybe disrupting
since i was already up a queen i felt
like i could make this kind of move
thanks moses so okay um
the reality is that let me say this the
threshold is a pawn
giving up a pawn or even two puns when
you're up a queen is fine giving up
a piece to do something like open a file
unless you're going to actively deliver
checkmate on that file isn't a great
idea and here's why now
the reason why is because if you go
knight f5 right
uh my king is not going to remain here
permanently
you know it's like when you get a cavity
on a tooth and that tooth is going to
fall out eventually it's like
consolation you know because where is
the king going to end up
it's gonna end up castling on the right
side right exactly and
uh this open file is about important as
important as owning a mansion and a
ghost town like it doesn't matter
anymore okay that's an amazing analogy
that will help you never forget
not to do this yeah was that something
you just made up on the spot
yeah literally no because because i was
reading about someone yesterday
and they were born in what's now a ghost
town and i started reading about ghost
towns
for absolutely no reason at all but yeah
nice and um that led me to the
philosophy oh did you know this uh
thing i might have brought this up to
you before like something like 97
of wikipedia pages if you click the
first hyperlink
in every page do you know where it
ultimately leads 97 of the time
wikipedia philosophy it leads to the
page on philosophy
okay i thought it was cool so people in
your chat can confirm this anyway it has
nothing to do with anything
so back to the game now queenie2
actually violates and i get what you're
doing now this help this makes sense
and i really like the fact that you fee
encountered the bishop because this does
block the natural development of the
queen
what would how can you develop and
defend this pawn if you were playing
conventionally here
oh i'd just bring the knight out bring
the knight out and how can you control
the center on the next move
i could either push pawn or just go d4
yeah so i would go d4 and d5 the way i
would go about opening the center
is just d45 you don't have to rush with
it you can complete your development
first but i actually kind of like the
creativity that went into the strategy
okay everything you did made sense
and the key moment so d4 right that
makes sense f4 would have been wrong
why blocks my the coverage of h4 exactly
and doesn't do anything to control the
center develop the bishop right
so you take on poisson h5 tracing the
knight away bishop g5
okay d5 so what would i do here d5 got
you into a little bit of a
tough situation uh if i'm volunteering
to open up a part of the board
and you're up a queen you accept that
with open arms so what would you do
i just take take it absolutely just take
the [ __ ] up on
oh take the freaking pot i don't even
know
uh if there are kids watching this they
should be in school anyway right or they
should be enjoying their break
exactly so that's my philosophy and now
you can just castle short
and or you can prepare castling long by
going knight c3
if i go bishop f5 where would you put
your queen
um well i was looking at a4 which gets a
pin on the king
kind of but you're about to castle
anyway so probably not there and i give
up a pawn for that
so i'd probably just wait what's that
you do give up a pawn
oh no i don't i do cover it you do cover
it and actually
um i like this one because the queen
is out of the way which is good and it
can get back into the king side so what
i want you to understand is that
piece piece placement is temporary uh
when you put a piece on a square
uh you shouldn't think about it as that
piece is going to be on that square
until the end of time
and if i castle short let's say some
random [ __ ] happens
and you know the queen can very easily
swing back to the other side of the
board
okay in addition you can use the queen
to deliver a fork find it
oh i see i'm delighted exactly
yep and you can see that even on a4 the
queen has utility
yeah so e5 and now knight a3 was the key
move
everything else you did made perfect
since roxy won castles rooksy sound was
awesome
bishop h3 now you see that this is
actually a bit of a mistake
last thing in this game if i had
actually taken on t5 how do you do
damage control in a situation like this
so shit's kind of falling apart here
what do you do
do i start looking for attacking
opportunities on king side so like
swinging king
or queen over to like g3 or something
like well then i take your rock
i'll like chop the legs off of that
whole operation yeah
i don't know how i save it though right
so what you need to do in such
situations and this is where people
really struggle
oh um wait do i bring queen to c3 oh no
then you just take the queen again jesus
right and the problem is if you bring
the queen to c1 and you try to save at
least something what does black do here
and try to go for the big prize here
don't rush
with like capturing the first piece that
comes to mind
guys is charlie's thinking i just want
to make a player fork on e2
fast good yeah 92 check so i would
probably go about
just taking on g7 if you're already
losing the rook you might as well give
it up for the maximum amount of
damage okay another thing you could do
is actually give up the queen for a
couple pieces so you could play rook
takes c8
okay what is the purpose of this move i
take your queen now
you don't want to take the knight yet
what do you want to do first i want to
take a rook
take a rook with check and now you're up
two entire pieces in an end game which
is completely winning so
that would be another thing to do the
logic should be if you're losing a piece
how do i give that piece up
for the maximum amount of damage okay
that makes sense
and the last yeah the story i was gonna
tell i'll make it quick when i played
bishop c8
um so i think i might have told i'll
keep this brief because it's not like
that funny
but the story goes to bobby fisher uh
was playing
in an olympiad and i don't know if you
know what an olympiad is every
two years it's like the chess olympics
like 150 countries
uh each team is is five players and
there's four boards and one alternate
and uh the olympiad is like a big deal
in the chess chess world because
you know countries are able to show
their superiority you can probably guess
what country was winning all the time in
the 60s 70s and 80s
was it russia it was russia but um
there were brief moments when you know
bobby fischer came around the us was
very competitive now
uh the us is basically top three every
olympiad because there's been this
influx of new players
but basically one olympiad bobby fischer
was a
pretty larger than life character and
you know everybody was trying to suck up
to him and not piss him off
uh because it was very easy to piss him
off and bobby fischer finishes his game
and he has his teammates over in his
hotel room to analyze the game he's
showing his game
and um they're all kind of an awe
display and they're all grandmasters
and at some point bobby fischer says and
here my opponent played
this move and he starts laughing his ass
off
and he can't stop laughing and his the
grandmaster is watching that game his
friend was telling the story
and he's laughing for a solid 10 minutes
and eventually all of his teammates
start
laughing with him but they understand
that the reason he's laughing is because
that move was so freaking terrible
that it caused him to just lose his [ __ ]
except they're not understanding why the
move was bad but they're just laughing
because they're afraid fisher will think
they're just as big
of idiots as his opponent is and anyways
that was the whole story
so i feel like that was how you felt
with my move yeah cause i was like
why can't you take the night and there
was this mutual understanding like i
know
why i can't take the knife obviously
but the reason is actually this fork
yeah okay okay
okay and the rest you did perfectly i
mean here moving the queen
forking the knights taking and then
getting the rook and sacrificing it on
g6 and crashing through
right
[Music]
you